business as usual in unusual times group
leaders in the newly elected parliament
led by acting president Gianni patella
visit Italy on the eve of its assumption
of the EU rotating presidency mr.
patella made his message clear am beemo
fertile govan italiano tutta la
collaborazione aid el parlamento robayo
para que se me strip residenza sia ew oh
so profi ho que pasa voltaren k delhi
misery inovative a Gehrig wat banan
saluto lock Rashida Alec reacciona pasa
la borre o la nación a Soledad phenomena
migracion a wall la ropa analysts fear a
globally back in Brussels his boss the
head of the Socialists and former
parliament President Martin Schultz and
his EPP counterpart Manfred vapor were
brainstorming on future directions yeah
Bonnie Lynn lately honor override
diffraction Tippett I did arrive on the
moon went ok set for the island and
endearing Machado and seafaring out
there on da Valen does this oven to cook
the look if it were the legacy on a stir
crazy is loosely visually mom Cleverley
zambia legacy and e-readers question the
part i and ii and such not soon Alice
most proper gear and we justif honest
you know too easily delicious tea and on
our vanity and anime and zipper Wendy
even arsenal st she glanced over shines
on internets another politic manzil this
week we learned that the French national
front of marine lepen missed the
deadline to form a group that leaves
Nigel Farage's anti-european group in a
stronger position but the reality is M
eps on the center who the majority and
will call the shots I think it's a lot a
lot of people who did not want to be
associated with what they perceive to be
real extremism and i think that's that's
where the failure of the from
nationalities is come from i think most
people who have form groups now have to
work very hard on the sort of cohesion
which is necessary we've got a really
exciting opportunity in this Parliament
as greens we've actually got positive
proposals for how to make Europe work
better for the citizens of you
up and that's around particularly
challenging corporate power and making
sure that the wishes of people are
actually paramount all eyes will be on
the Parliament when it meets on July the
first for the first session of the new
term and on the willingness and capacity
of em EPS to fulfill the promises they
have made